pendant que cela ça se passe à toronto à
montréal aussi pas mal d'action julis
aussi et pdg de l'association
professionnelle des courtiers
immobiliers du québec bonsoir on soit 21
trimestres de hausse 21 trimestres de
hausse de suite dans le marché
résidentiel de montréal est ce qu'on a
déjà vu cela
ça fait très très longtemps qu'on a déjà
qu'on a pas vu ça c'est vraiment on bat
des records de trimestre en trimestre on
se dit est ce que ça va arrêter mais non
ça ça se poursuit ça se poursuit
toujours et si on vous invite on va
regarder des tableaux qui vont expliquer
pourquoi on fait une émission spéciale
dans une heure premier tableau sur les
maisons unifamiliales l'état des ventes
les inscriptions le prix médian
également maisons unifamiliales au mois
d'octobre 2010 9 à montréal 2220 ventes
en hausse de 14%
les inscriptions ont baissé de 15%
madame soucier donc vraiment sans une
une une baisse de l'offre
une hausse de la demande exactement
c'est un marché qui est extraordinaire
pour les vendeurs mais très difficile
pour les acheteurs parce que
l'inventaire de maisons diminue
grandement et donc le prix médian a
augmenté vite % à 355 milles et
expliquer un petit peu le délai de vente
moyen baisse de 15 jours ça 3 59 jours
en moyenne vont d'une maison
unifamiliale exactement
donc est ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est
que nous on fonctionne beaucoup avec
cette donnée là c'est important pour
nous de bien comprendre et d'évaluer le
marché habituellement
pour considérer que le marché est très
serré on dit que c'est entre 90 et 150
jours et vous voyez présentement monte à
59 jours donc ses riffs 90 à 150 l'on
est à 59 pas je suis le traître sb20
serré donc on passe comme ça qu'on parle
de surchauffe pour ça qu'on parle de
surenchère parce que tout cela entraîne
le fait que c'est beaucoup plus
difficile de trouver des maisons surtout
dans certains quartiers de montréal tous
les quartiers de montréal où certains
quartiers ben en fait les quartiers
centre c'était beaucoup plus difficile
maintenant c est à peu près impossible
de se trouver des maisons
vous voyez le sa part très très
rapidement que ce soit pour les maisons
unifamiliales pour les plex ou encore
pour les condos on voit exactement la
même chose donc ce qu'on se rend compte
que c'est vraiment des quartiers qui
aurait pas ce problème l'eau qui a ses
problèmes là présentement qu'on parle
des quartiers comme villeré comme le
plateau le plateau c'est plus au centre
mais comme belgacom le mile end comme
verdun c'est tous des endroits où on
voit que c'est en train de 7 en train de
s'étendre
donc ça c'est la maison unifamiliale 59
jours seulement le délai on va regarder
copropriété et les plex dans les
copropriétés les ventes sont en
augmentation également 11 %
d'augmentation pour les ventes 1509
copropriété en octobre 2019 dans le
marché montréalais
les inscriptions 5750 baisse de 28% donc
de moins en moins d'inscriptions c'est
exactement ça les prix médians le prix
médian 280000 donc aux 6% et le délai de
vente 69 jours soit un peu plus élevé
que le nid familial mais c'est une
baisse de 20 jours par rapport à l'an
passé exactement
donc c'est aussi très serré c'est la
même chose on parle de 90 à 150
on est en dessous de beaucoup de ce
concert comme un marché qui est serré et
dans les plex donc duplex triplex
quadruplex deux à cinq logements dans
les plex également ya beaucoup de
mouvement voilà bouge pas mal dans les
paddocks
parce que c'est un investissement les
plex aussi un investissement il y en a
de moins en moins il ya plus de
construction de plex donc sacrés
encore plus de rareté la raison pour
laquelle on voit que les chiffres sont
exactement la même chose
alors pour me le mois d'octobre 2010 9
466 vente une hausse de 22%
les inscriptions 1916 c'est une baisse
de 20% le prix médian 560000 en hausse
de 7%
le délai de vente est un peu plus long
il ya même augmenter un petit peu de
quatre jours 74 jours on est quand même
à 74 jours ce qui est quand même très
bon ce qui est quand même très bas
effectivement par rapport à la zone de
90 à 150 donc on n'est pas dans un
marché de ralentissement est ce qu'on en
voit un ralentissement est ce qu'on
imagine que ça peut se calmer ou au
contraire
cette surchauffe est vraiment parti pour
de bon mais pour les prochains mois
c'est sûr que ça va se poursuivre on
voit pas vraiment avec avec les taux
d'intérêt qui demeure à peu près les
mêmes on voit pas pourquoi il devrait
avoir un mouvement au niveau où un
ralentissement au niveau du marché
par contre avec l'économie qui devrait
ralentir un petit peu probablement dans
la prochaine année
il reprend pas un règlement
ralentissement mais malgré tout c'est
des chiffres qui est qui demeurent ou
dessous des espérances de tout le monde
est-ce que ce phénomène est vraiment
concentré d'un gros mot non parce que
étant donné la rareté des logements à
l'intérieur de la région métropolitaine
de recensement de montréal
mais c'est sûr que l'on est en train de
déborder que ce soit en périphérie du
côté de la rive sud du côté de la rive
nord
on voit de plus en plus que de la
surchauffe là aussi les marchés comme
saint jean sur richelieu lasalle bouge
pas mal c'est incroyable c'est un des
marchés qui est elle si on regarde du
côté de la rive sud
c'est un des marchés où il ya le plus
d'activités présentement bien madame
soucier merci beaucoup ça nous donne le
portrait est la raison fondamentale
pourquoi on fait cette émission spéciale
ce soir merci beaucoup madame soucier
merci à vous